[موسيقى]
إذا اشتهرت إيبيزا بشيء واحد ،
فهذه الموسيقى النابضة بالقرب من
أشعة الشمس المستمرة والشواطئ الجميلة تجذب
السائحين عن طريق القارب الذي
يعبئ هاربورفرونت في شوارع البلدة
القديمة وبالطبع النادي هذا العام كانت
جميع الأماكن الكبرى تروج
أشهر الأسماء في موسيقى المنزل ، كان Guetta
ثم Buuren Black Coffee 2020
يبني ليكون عامًا لافتًا ،
ووصل العرض رقم 19
يبدو وكأنه في الصباح بعد
ليلة صاخبة في الخارج ، إنه يشبه إلى حد بعيد
الجياع روبرتو دي لا بايكس هو مدير نادي
لـ  الشركة التي تدير
ملهى ليليًا مرتفعًا في أوشوايا يستوعب 7000
شخص ، لقد صنعنا بالفعل الموسم
هنا ، الصيف هنا ولا يوجد
حديد مسطح ولا رحلات جوية لا توجد قوارب
ولا توجد تنقلات بين
الحدود في أوروبا إنه أمر
صعب حقًا  خاصةً عندما
يشمل عملك الآلاف من
الأشخاص يتكاتفون جنبًا إلى جنب على
حلبة الرقص حتى بعد أن ترفع إسبانيا
قفلها ، فإن إرادتها الطبيعية الجديدة  لا تزال
بحاجة
إلى تباعد اجتماعي ، هل هناك أي طريقة للوصول إلى مسافة اجتماعية في ملهى ليلي
، فلا توجد طريقة للقيام بذلك
بدون أي لقاح في هذه الأثناء ،
يعمل رئيس Lopez على
تجربة نوادي الواقع الافتراضي ،
ويستضيف نادي العاطفة الشهير
حفلات منزلية فعلية  منسقو الأغاني المشهورين الذين يدورون بسرعة كبيرة
'للآلاف في غرف معيشتهم ،
كان التأثير رهيبًا ،
والصناعة الوحيدة التي لدينا هي صناعة السياحة ،
لذا لا يوجد الآن أشخاص قادمون ،
Vicente Marie هو رئيس
الجزيرة الذي يستقبل أكثر من 3
ملايين زائر كل عام  الغالبية
العظمى من الخارج مقطوعة عن
البر الرئيسي عن طريق البحر الأبيض المتوسط لم تسجل إي
يزا سوى 186 حالة و 13 حالة وفاة تر
د ماري أن ترى عودة السائحين في أسرع وقت ممكن ول
س الفيروس هناك ضروري لفرض ضو
بط في جميع المطارات للسيطرة عل
الأشخاص الذين يأتون.  خالي من
اختبار الفيروسات ، الاختبار هو الطريقة الوحيدة
للقيام بالسياحة مرة أخرى حتى
تتغلب على هذه الحياة الليلية ، وعلينا الانتظار
معها  الموسيقى في نفس الوقت بدون أندية ،
الأمر مختلف ، يمكنك أن
تكون betta بالتأكيد ولكنك لن
تشعر بنفس الشعور الذي لن تشعر به
هناك أنهم حقيقيون هم Evita
Scott McLean CNN لقد تغلب على الجنون